Так гатять німецькі самохідні гармати Panzerhaubitze 2000.
Збройні сили України вже активно використовують їх на фронті.
Німеччина надала два десятки цих систем. Водночас офіційний Київ не розуміє,
чому німецький уряд поставляє в Україну ці броньовані артилерійські установки,
але вагається, коли мова йде про бойові танки.
За словами глави українського МЗС Дмитра Кулеби, лінія аргументації Берліна незрозуміла,
адже якщо Україна буде недостатньо озброєна, війна затягнеться -
а це не в інтересах ані України, ані її західних партнерів.
Німецька сторона вже продемонструвала лідерство у постачанні систем
протиракетної оброни IRIS-T та іншого важливого озброєння.
Ми розраховуємо на лідерство і в передачі "Патріотів", танків Leopard 2 та БМП Marder.
Не може бути жодних табу в питаннях допомоги Україні зброєю
для захисту всієї Європи від збройної агресії Російської Федерації.
На одній з останніх урядових пресконференцій у Берліні DW прямо запитала,
чи постачатиме Німеччина сучасні танки Leopard 2 Україні.
Такої можливості представник міністерства оборони не підтвердив, але й не спростував.
За даними німецького видання Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung,
США ще у жовтні сигналізували Німеччині, що схвалюють постачання в Україну
німецьких бойових танків Leopard 2. Заступниця офіційного представника уряду ФРН Крістіане Гоффман
зауважила, що поки жодна західна держава не надала Україні танки,
і Німеччина в цьому питанні не діятиме самотужки.
Ви знаєте, що наш принцип полягає в тому, що ми не хочемо діяти поодинці
і не маємо наміру цього робити. Ми дуже тісно координуватимемо наші дії.
Зовнішньополітичний радник Плетнер та радник з національної безпеки США Салліван
активно контактують один з одним. Можу сказати, що ніколи не було жодного тиску
з американського боку чи прохання про постачання бойових танків Leopard 2.
У статті Frankfurter Allgemeine вказують на те, що, можливо, у Німеччині чекають,
доки США першими поставлять танки в Україну.
Однак більш ефективним був би зворотний порядок поставок.
Тому Україна могла б мати танки цього типу, які можна обслуговувати по той бік
українського кордону в Польщі. З американськими танками це поки що неможливо, сказав він.
"Є об'єктивні підстави сказати: спочатку Leopard 2", - каже Ґрессель.
За словами експерта, лише із запасів виробників Rheinmetall та Krauss-Maffei Wegmann
Німеччина могла б надати 80 одиниць у найкоротші строки.
На підтвердження цієї логіки щодо постачання військової техніки і подальшого її обслуговування
у Словаччині неподалік кордону з Україною вже лагодять німецьку зброю.
Там розпочав роботу ремонтний центр німецької військової техніки,
переданої ЗСУ й пошкодженої під час бойових дій проти Росії.
Зокрема, планують ремонтувати вже згадані німецькі броньовані
самохідні гармати Panzerhaubitze 2000.
Якщо гаубиця може знаходитися на більшій відстані від лінії фронту, її можна убезпечити,
то танки - це зброя прориву, вони діють у першій лінії у наступі
і знаходяться на передньому краю, і відповідно до цього навіть з математичної точки зору
вірогідність їх ураження є більшою. І після кожного ураження вивозити ті танки за кордон
і ремонтувати десь у Німеччині, не маючи такої підготовленої системи експлуатації
й обслуговування та ремонту на території України або у найближчих країна-сусідах,
було б просто неприпустимо з точки зору ефективності використання
тих систем і надзвичайно дорого.
Активна фаза обговорення постачання Києву німецьких танків Leopard 2
триває вже кілька місяців. Канцлер ФРН Олаф Шольц щоразу відхиляє прохання Києва
про постачання танків, повторюючи, як мантру, що Берлін не буде "діяти поодинці"
у питаннях постачання озброєнь, натякаючи на США та позицію інших членів НАТО,
які також не постачають Києву танки західного виробництва.
При цьому офіційний Вашингтон наприкінці минулого тижня спростував чутки про те,
що США cтримують Німеччину від поставок в Україну сучасних танків.
За словами заступниці держсекретаря США Венді Шерман, Сполучені Штати
не мають заперечень щодо поставок в Україну німецьких танків Leopard 2,
зенітно-ракетних комплексів ППО та ПРО Patriot, які наполегливо просить Київ.
До цього деякі аналітики припускали, що є консолідоване рішення НАТО
про неприйнятність таких поставок. Досі країни-члени Альянсу постачали Україні
лише танки радянського виробництва. Фактично слова представниці Держдепу США
означають, що зобов'язань перед союзниками не постачати Україні Leopard 2
Німеччина не має.
Однак Берлін може керуватися у цьому рішенні й іншими причинами.
Треба ще розібратися, коли ці танки продукувалися, і навіть якщо вони знаходилися
на зберіганні, пройшов дуже тривалий термін цього зберігання.
І такі танки потребують просто колосальної затрати коштів для їх відновлення.
Чи призначені ті кошти бюджетом ФРН? Мабуть, що ні.
Треба їх призначати? Так. Треба. Яка робота має проводитись? Колосальна.
Тому що відновити техніку, яка простояла на сховищах десь по 15-20 років,
це досить тривалий і складний процес. Таким чином навіть без політичних,
конспірологічних теорій ми бачимо, що цей процес пов'язаний з логістикою,
ефективністю експлуатації техніки, вимагає часу і відповідної підготовки,
з чим і може бути пов’язана з точки зору здорового глузду і ситуація з тим,
чому ці танки до сих пір не поступили на озброєння української армії.
При цьому Німеччина надала Україні нові зобов’язання про постачання зброї
для протистояння повномасштабному російському вторгненню.
Про це в інтерв’ю німецькому виданню Welt am Sonntag розповів
посол України в Німеччині Олексій Макеєв.
За словами оглядачів, Україна дещо змінила тактику і новий посол України у Німеччині
Олексій Макеєв нині заходить більше з флангів, без лобових атак - на відміну від свого попередника
Андрія Мельника, відомого своїми гострими заявами
і випадами на адресу німецьких політиків.
Для уряду ФРН досі було негласним табу бачити німецькі танки на тих же полях боїв,
що й під час Другої світової. Нині ж ставлення до цього поступово змінюється.
Приміром, голова оборонного комітету Бундестагу, як і чимало інших парламентарів,
які входять до правлячої коаліції, вже активно виступає за відправку танків в Україну.
На думку експертів, вчорашній скептицизм німецького уряду перетворюється
на сьогоднішнє "можливо", а завтра - на "ми цим пишаємося".
Останні місяці показали, наскільки ефективніша західна зброя за стару радянську.
Тим більше, що радянські боєприпаси вже вичерпуються. А той аргумент, що українці
не вміють поводитися із західною зброєю, також слабшає, бо за 10 місяців війни
українські військові вже показали, що вміють швидко опановувати сучасне озброєння.